bonjour marc ses fils bonjour maurice
violland et bonjour à tous les auditeurs
de martinique 1ère vous êtes un
président du comité de soutien à alain
juppé est l'un des sept candidats à la
primaire de la droite et du sang des
primaires on le rappelle qui auront lieu
les 19 et 26 novembre en martinique et
marque ses fils ça commence à devenir
franchement nauséabond cette campagne
sur le thème de l'identité de l'histoire
des petites phrases dit là-bas
empoisonnent la vie des militants d'ici
échoppes les autres dernier exemple le
mouvement international des réparations
qui porte plainte contre françois fillon
sur ses propos à propos de l' esclavage
période de partage selon lui la culture
française auprès d'autres d'autres pays
comment vous jugez tout cela nous avons
jusqu à le dire nul mais c'est vrai que
vous avez raison il faut que nous ayons
une manière de porter cette campagne à
ceux d'autres thèmes que l'identité
parce qu'ils ont élevé le débat oui et
puis il y a aussi d'autres quoi que le
débat sur l'identité peut être élu et
aussi sais pas mais il ya d'autres
thèmes il ya d'autres préoccupations des
martiniquais et du français en général
c'est le chômage c'est le le le
les abysses compte que que touchent les
les fonds publics les déficits publics
qui sont très très très abyssaux
aujourd'hui il y à un certain nombre de
problèmes du quotidien des gens qui
doivent être réglés même si c'est vrai
que l'homme ne se nourrit pas seulement
de pain il faut aussi parler de ce qu on
est dessus mais ça devrait pas être le
thème central d'une campagne à la jupe
est votre candidat le maire de bordeaux
estime qu'il faudrait relever le niveau
des discussions tout cas il dit que le
débat politique est nul mais qu'at-il
fait pour relever ce débat justement
bain sur l'identité heureuse et puis
l'identité heureuse par exemple c'est un
thème de l'identité mais qui n'est pas
destiné à cliver qui n'est pas destiné à
monter les français les uns contre les
autres mais sait-on sur france 2 n'est
pas heureux non ce n'est pas un slogan
c'est un objectif
c'est l'objectif de la rue lorsque la
femme de la rue v de payer ses impôts
dans son rapport au déficit aujourd'hui
rochelle organisé lié à d'autres il y à
d'autres thèmes de campagne et alain
juppé a affirmé par un programme qu'il
décline depuis à peu près deux ans et
puis surtout une méthode une méthode
parce qu'on sait et tout le monde le dit
qu il faut réformer un certain nombre de
choses en france et il y a une méthode
juppé qui est la suivante c'est à dire
qu'il faut apaiser justement donc il
faut apaiser
il faut rassembler et il faut réformer
ensuite émettre et sur terre lune
l'identité heureux ce matin dans le
journal ib et le journal le monde
livre quand même le risque de guerre
civile dans ce contexte sécuritaire
tendu alors quelque part il met le feu
il est un met pas le feu
c'est un constat à vouloir exacerbé ce
type de peau de ce type de deux thèmes
si vous voulez à vouloir avoir des
propos sur un certain nombre de thèmes
et qui sont clivant et avoir une
orientation clivante là dessus si sûr
que en 2d se dirige vers
quelque chose de pas très bon gars
civile sais pas si c'est ce qu'il écrit
en tout cas sûrement mais il a peut-être
il a une autre niveau d'information que
le nôtre n'est pas connue pas du vôtre
mais du mien en tout cas je pense
pendant 35 ans d'une premier ministre
ont tout simplement et je pense que s'il
le dit peut-être qu'il a des références
proulx ça en tout cas si je vais que ce
qu'il veut dire c'est que ça monte les
français les uns contre les autres
d'avoir toujours des débats sur sa voix
qui on n'est qu' on n'est pas moi je
pense qu'il faut comme il dit dans son
tweet il faut plutôt parler d'avenir
parler avenir aux jeunes français aux
jeunes martiniquais
je lui redonner un espoir et cet espoir
s'est pas sur le thème de l'identité par
exemple c'est justement cette identité
heureuse et pas non et non pas un repli
identitaire et non pas se focaliser sur
notre nombril mais plutôt regarder
l'avenir parce que le monde le monde est
à nous et si ça qu'on dit aux jeunes le
monde et à nous prenons le mais avec
avec la connaissance de ses racines
alain juppé estime sur la tête toujours
qu'il est le seul à pouvoir devancer
marine le pen au premier tour de la
présidentielle et la battre largement au
second
la question c'est quoi
vous êtes convaincu a bien sûr sans quoi
je ne l'aurais pas pris l'animation va
et du président d'honneur
chez nous on a des animateurs je ne vais
pas pris là l'animation de son comité à
la martinique si joli coin est paru si
j'ai le temps je n'ai pas l'habitude
d'aller dans un contexte politique dont
je n'aime pas le mot combat parce qu'il
faut apaiser justement sans en pensant
que je vais perdre c'est parce que je
pense que les idées que nous portons
sont celles qu'il faut il faut il faut
aller les faire connaître et d'ailleurs
y ont selon nous avons eu une réunion
des membres du comité où il y avait une
soixantaine de personnes est avec nous
et nous allons décliner le plan de
campagne et nous allons repartir
pas seulement pour parler des thèmes de
l'identité mais du quotidien des
martinis alors justement sur le site
d'alain juppé sur l'onglet outre-mer il
estime que nos pays ne sont pas une
charge
ou une contrainte pour la france mais un
atout politique économique et humain ça
c'est la grosse daube
tout le monde sort ça de la daube pour
vous peut-être pas pourquoi ils l'ont
une fois qu'on a dit à l'ats réalisé en
berne après je pense que vous n'avez pas
cliqué assez longtemps merci je ne
l'avais pas cliqué assez longtemps
peut-être si vrai que quand on est
journaliste on a beau il faut vous
faudra qu'il écrit il y a une qu'il ya
grand développement blague à part il est
un grand développement le développement
était sur deux pages mais je vous
annonce généralement ça se coupe le
samedi 1er octobre
on présentera à paris les les
les propositions d'alain juppé mais ce
que je veux dire c'est faux c'est que
pour les outremers même si je n'aime pas
le mot je ne suis pas fini aussi le 18
le 18 juin dernier nous avons fait le
comité martinique d'un ajout puis nous
avons fait une conférence débat dans
laquelle nous présentions les thèmes de
campagne que nous allons porter et les
propositions que nous avons faites à
alain juppé nous avons fait qu'on monte
en dise on travaille et on a travaillé
toutes les vacances et aujourd'hui donc
nous allons sortir ce cahier c'est parce
que ça va se décliner sous forme de
cahier nous allons sortir ce cahier qui
dit là les propositions d'alain juppé ou
de ses fils
vous êtes dans ce circuit politique
depuis quelques années vous savez très
bien qu'il y à ce qu'on dit concernant
nos pays et puis cette réalité de bercy
nos pays coûte trop cher il faut ceci il
faut cela il faut réduire on ne va pas
plus loin que cela concerne à la
défiscalisation yan monplaisir qui
soutient sarkozy le dise le disait
également il ne faut pas de simples
mesures est pour nos pays
vous savez qui était ministre du budget
quand on a mis en place la
défiscalisation
je vous la donne en plein dans le mille
si monsieur juppé donc il est convaincu
que pour nous il connaît il connaît nos
is right and hope aiguille je crois
alain juppé alain juppé ça fait 50 ans
qui vit en martinique depuis les années
60 il venait à martin il ya quelques
années mars et file vers 2011-2012
vous disiez que nicolas sarkozy était
celui qui avait fait le plus pour nos
pays
vous savez après la crise 2
neuf avec willow ciom lejaby terminé
parce que j'ai dit par contre
aujourd'hui pour l'avenir
moi je pense que si un autre candidat et
notamment alain juppé qui peut faire là
j'ai envie de faire confiance à nicolas
sarkozy lui qui avait déjà obligé pas
envie d'entrer dans ce débat moi je suis
pas je suis pas je ne suis pas je suis
pour juppé je suis pas contre sarkozy
on est d'accord et ma famille politique
faire un choix
les 19 et 26 novembre pour la martinique
puisqu'on vote selon le format des
élections nationales
je fais mon choix
les urnes ou savez vous savez nous
sommes partis démocratiques
on vous l'a démontré en janvier dernier
il ya des élèves sur péter à il ya des
élections
d'autres élections notamment pour la
primaire pour choisir le candidat qui va
défendre nos couleurs à la
présidentielle de 2017
le choix sera fait tout le monde se la
jouer derrière le candidat qui a gagné
et puis qu'est-ce que cette campagne est
ce que cette campagne campagne mais
est-ce qui se faufile à se battre au
sein des valides et laisse des traces
entre supporters de nicolas sarkozy
supporters d'alain juppé supporters de
françois lange et espère que non
j'espère que non j'espère que non c'est
tout le souhait que je peux formuler des
dents c'est en tout cas vu dans ces
propos de nicolas sarkozy ont cédé dans
la famille des républicains sera ça crée
des remous quand même non ça crée pas d
eux moussa on dit ce qu'on pense andy ce
qu'on pense c'est un débat d'idées
ce n'est pas un débat sur les hommes
comment vous ferez pour convaincre ceux
qui iront voter rappelle que sur le
papier théorique mais devrait avoir au
moins un bureau de vote dans chaque
commune risque à nouveau je vois comment
comment vous allez faire pour porter la
bonne parole
bien avant nous avons justement décliner
le la le plan de campagne du comité
juppé et nous allons passer dans toutes
les communes de la martinique
nous allons faire de la politique c'est
pas de la politique politicienne mais de
la vraie c'est aller vers le vert les
lecteurs vers le martiniquais pour lui
porter la parole alain juppé merci
d'avoir été ce matin avec nos marques
ses fils rappelle que vous êtes le
président du club alsacien
l'animateur du comité de soutien à alain
juppé le 17 candidats à la primaire de
la droite et du centre et c'était ça
aurait dis merci bonne journée